en esta pequeña tienda de bangkok venden
unas golosinas muy especiales son de
colores de sabores y dulces y contienen
un ingrediente inesperado
cannabis
y no solo tenemos que saber cómo
controlarlos para que los niños no
tengan acceso a ellos y también tenemos
que enseñar a la gente a utilizarlos
para asegurarnos de que los usen de
forma segura y responsable
cuatro años después de la
despenalización del uso terapéutico del
cannabis
tailandia flexibilizar un poco más su
legislación ahora autoriza su cultivo y
uso en productos alimenticios y
cosméticos con la condición de que no
supere una concentración del 0.2 por
ciento del thc el componente psicoactivo
de la planta pero esto es inaudito en
asia y el primer cliente de esta tienda
fue recibido como un héroe
empecé a hacer cola el día antes de la
inauguración salí del trabajo me duché y
tomé el autobús hasta aquí sabía que la
tienda estaba cerrada pero espere aquí
con una cerveza así vi cómo se
organizaba el personal quería ser
testigo del inicio del camino
tailandia espera que el nuevo mercado
impulse la economía especialmente el
turismo que se ha visto muy afectado por
la pandemia el gobierno espera ganar 15
mil millones de baht unos 400 millones
de euros para el 2026